mark off-camera we were talking about
your moving out to Santa Barbara UCSB
from the East Coast you didn't know
anyone so you have a bachelor's in film
studies and then a master's in motion
picture and new things we're producing
ok great
what did those degrees prepare you for
and in the long run now looking back on
it what classes do you think we're
missing from the curriculum well so
Santa Barbara was much more critical
studies not so much production when I
had applied out here I I was
transferring as a junior so there was no
time for me to sort of work my way into
the film program I had to get into the
film program or we're bust and I didn't
get into UCLA at all and USC I got into
but I didn't get into the film program
and so Santa Barbara was at the time it
was only one that accepted me I was I
was a little bit if he on going to Santa
Barbara he'd never been there and I was
like oh you know they're too far from LA
oh it's film studies and not production
and my dad stopped seems like you'll
like it and I go yeah I don't know
you'll like it
he just stopped me is like you'll like
it trust me so I just jumped on a plane
a week before school started in just
lesson if I never visited the campus I
was like yeah and when I got there man I
was like wow did I hit the honey pot it
was yeah it was something just just kind
of going through the campus on that
first day and so uh you know I think a
lot of the classes there it gave me a
very good background in terms of you
know the film classics and what you know
kind of what Jenner what what what in
those films generated such a response
from from audiences what was it and you
know in terms of how they spoke to that
generation and what themes were in there
and just really kind of studying the
anatomy of the film there was also some
production but it was a lot of it was
really just studies so you know it was a
different type of education and I
expected but maybe was the platform that
I kind of needed before I you know
before I jumped in to
to working in the film industry getting
that sort of understanding about classic
films and and who made them and why they
made them and how they affected people
but you know I don't know if when I was
taking the classes if there was any
necessary class that I thought wasn't
you know that was missing from the
curriculum I mean we had a lot of I you
know you know there was there was a porn
class which I didn't take I actually
taught a porn class directing we were
starring just just analyzing porn folk
yeah again who because of his studies
Wow there was like you know I'm John
Chinese cinema I mean you want to learn
about nineteen fifties Swedish cinema
mean there was like classes on just
about everything and there were certain
mandatory ones you know that you had to
take like you know that 101 series was
films on the first second section was
films on the silent era then on soar the
era from the advent of sound up through
the Paramount decree when they sort of
like D integrated the all the all the
students were vertically integrated the
control of the theaters the distribution
and the production so up until sort of
when the government got involved and
said no you can't actually have movie
screens as well you can't own an
exhibition distribution and production
and then the last water section was up
from there up to modern day cinema so we
even watched like The Matrix is some
size and analyze that and I think it
just gave me a platform and an
understanding of and you know film
content and storytelling that you know
laid a nice platform before before I got
involved in the actual production so
that was Santa Barbara and then UCLA was
was definitely you know in terms of a
producing program a lot more oriented
toward the business of filmmaking so you
know I had what I liked about UCLA I'm
not am a huge fan of academics I'm not a
huge fan of people that just teach and
haven't done or haven't done in 20 years
I like I like to learn from the people
who are doing it now and so UCLA's
professors were all people that were
working at the time so like my marketing
professor was Terry press who was the
head of all of DreamWorks marketing and
her boss boss was Steven Spielberg like
she was the top of
Marketing and she came and taught a
class for you know three hours every
Wednesday night or whatever was learning
marketing from her it's like you're
learning from the best or Eric Baum who
is the senior VP of business affairs
that Sony was my contracts and
negotiations professor he was doing it
at the time he'd come teach the class at
night so yeah I learned a lot I would
say my probably my two biggest mentors
there were Megillah foe who was Jodie
Foster's producing partner at the time
and she just a genius at script
development just an absolute genius
and then Merle schribman who we taught
me production and I produced a few
actual projects within UCLA and so I
would say you know they were probably my
two biggest mentors I'd say in terms of
you know classes that might have been
missing there was no new media hadn't
really you know become a thing yet even
though it was sort of in the NASA and
stages so because this was a one two oh
three would be pre-youtube
but at the time I was creating cd-rom
media packages for artists this up so
there was an asset new media sphere and
there wasn't a lot I think it was really
maybe almost too early but there wasn't
a lot in the producers program for that
was mostly traditional film and
television so but I didn't feel like men
I wish they had you know more of this or
that or the other there I felt like I
got out of it what I wanted to get out
of it and on the weekends or days off
were you taking the train down to LA
while you're in Santa Barbara
I had a car Oh yet Clark I did and I was
interning in my so like I said I came in
at Santa Barbara my junior year so I was
there for two years junior senior so
during my senior year I interned at film
Roman where they do the Simpsons
ah but I interned for the feature film
department which I don't even think is a
real I don't know if they're around
anymore I don't think they're but
they're reference Mull time they did a
movie called my first mister with
Christine Lahti and they were in
development on on a number of other
things so I did intern for them
and it was a good experience I mean I
yeah I started doing coverage of
learning how to do coverage and just you
know understanding what they were
looking for in a script that was my
first sort of practical hands-on
experience in Los Angeles and it was
good one
that was good so it prepared you so
Santa Barbara is is a beautiful amazing
place and and I would love to live there
now but it is a bubble of happiness and
sunshine and things and so to come back
to Hollywood and struggle for a parking
spot and finding a place to live that's
safe you know it's can be a little I was
just wondering what that culture shock
was like a little bit so oh yeah because
I think because I had made a very good
friend when I first moved to Santa
Barbara I think everything happens for a
reason you meet the people you need to
meet at the right times and so this guy
Doug that I had met in my firm you know
within the first few weeks ago into
Santa Barbara this guy was like mr.
California I mean he had moved out here
from West Virginia and just love it
again if you said anything even halfway
sideways against California he would
like he'd go off what are you talking
about man it's the best Sheena Barbara
loan has 1500 you know species a plant
they're indigenous only the Santa
Barbara what are you talking about like
this guy would convince me to cut class
and go play volleyball with him go
mountain hiking with Tom I mean this guy
like loved everything about the state
love being outdoors and so he took me to
LA a few times like we would go take
road trips and go down to Los Angeles
and he just knew everything not just
about Santa Barbara but the whole you
know southern seaboard it seemed like
and so between that and the internship
I'd come down to LA enough events you
know some with some other friends there
you know and just even even some class
trips I remember we took one from one
from Santa Barbara and went to CBS
television city to watch a show being
taped and talked to the producers day so
I'd come down enough that I you know I
kind of felt comfortable enough with it
and it didn't seem as much of a culture
shock when I moved down here you know
Kolchak was Philadelphia Santa Barbara
that was the culture shock it was so
different I bet yeah from hoagies to the
submarine sandwiches or whatever ya know
it was a big it was it was a big
difference in terms of I think I think
for like two weeks all I did was stare
at palm
and license plates because this is
California and like the palms right now
this is like you know wow I'm here
because California license plates and
palm trees are two things you don't see
you in Philadelphia you know I mean I
just think I was just so enamored with
just for the first few weeks you know
just being I was like wow I'm actually
here so my time I went to LA it was more
just it kind of it's just a lateral move
it's like okay now that's where I need
to live but I had and I had visited a
like many many times before I even moved
to Santa Barbara so I'd been on vacation
and I'd been in Los Angeles so it wasn't
it wasn't a huge shock so fast forward a
few years your first producing job what
was it what did it teach you how did you
get it so I guess my first producing job
out of school happened I had met met up
with an old friend
Jesse my became my producing partner for
11 years we're producing partners and we
had met up and having lunch or hanging
out or whatever and he said he said you
know I'm doing music videos you know how
would you feel about directing a music
video because I had done a little bit of
directing in college and like you know I
wasn't sure that's what I wanted to do
like you know do I really have a passion
for directing and I said I said how
really no music videos that well what if
I just produced it with you and kind of
you know sort of got my bearings and
really saw what it was about and you
know I felt like I was good putting
stuff together and then you know as I
work on if there's a specific area that
I really like we can you know maybe I
can discuss with you and if it's
directing if it's something else I can
discuss that with you so this first
music video was for a group called the
real seduction they're like an R&B group
they were they were MC Hammer's like
backup singer dancers you know the guys
like beyond they started their own R&B
group and and I yes so I remember like
he had hit them up for I can't remember
what the budget was five or six grand
sixty five hundred bucks maybe and back
then everything was thirty
five-millimeter there was no this stuff
is not being shot on digital video not
at least at a professional level so we
were doing 35 mil and as I started
working with him I mean I realized
somebody needs to actually physically
put this together I didn't at the time
really understand the difference between
a line producer or a upm a producer I'm
just like I just know somebody needs to
put this together so I just sort of
jumped into that line producer upm role
and started like finding crew and
booking the equipment and we got to find
locations and we hired a director and I
was like now I like this because I get
to be part of everything it to be part
of every single part of the process as
opposed to just one and you know
throughout post even long after the
director is gone you know I get to you
know all the way through delivery to the
client I get to be part of the whole
thing so so that music video was the
start I think of my interest I hadn't
necessarily decided for a fact that yes
a hundred percent I wanna produce but I
started liking it I started liking that
hands-on like wow this is cool I get to
make I'm the one I'm the guy that's
making the decisions I get to say yes or
no you know I was very creative
I was very creative position and so from
there I think it's sort of escalated and
we started doing
once you have one music video and you
can show it to a band and they're like
wow this is great
we got five grands do it so my partner
and I were running around Sunset
Boulevard hitting up bands at clubs and
however we can meet them hustling we
were we were auslan and that's how we
that's how we started just doing music
videos yeah we would you find the crew
and you know the directors and things
were like where were you actually
finding it well yeah so yeah back then
there wasn't all these nests you know
social net was no social networks and
there wasn't things like that I mean I
guess a lot of it was if I'm a so long
ago word of mouth to think how I first
built up my crew relationships like I
guess a lot of it was word of mouth so
jesse had already been down in LA for a
year so you know I know he he knew some
people's like hey you know I got this
director I think he can do it and that
director had to DP so it's like I'll
make sure I mean my little database okay
make sure that a lot of that guy the
tepees info in for future and then that
deep he's like I'll bring out my team oh
hey there's some ACS and you know so a
lot of is just networking and
word-of-mouth you know I think a lot of
it probably also was going to event
something
so networking events and some of it was
some of its school you know I mean there
there are people that you go to school
with me I went to UCLA and oh one about
a year after I moved down to LA so there
were definitely some what once you're in
a master's level program all of those
people are that's what they're gonna be
doing it's not like their chemistry
majors but they really want to do
something else
once your math in a master's program
it's usually like that's your career
trajectory so I met I did meet actors
and DPS and production designers and
stuff at UCLA and I think that also
helped you know helped me grow my crew
base it's a lot of yeah it's
relationships when you went to these
clubs or events on the Sunset Strip I
mean were you going to like gazzarri's
or maybe I'm dating myself with that one
with a rainbow and and in Roxy right
okay it's so Derby right okay we cannot
remind think that's around anymore but
yeah you and I probably both yeah I
think the FM station I'm probably dating
myself with that one but yeah I think
that was almost like post you know that
was more grunge era but were yeah well
after the grunge era but there was still
a lot like the Key Club that like that's
ranked anymore yeah so and what was your
approach at this you were just you know
I mean it was easy to talk to people
there was no phones people weren't
pulling out phones to take a selfie with
I mean I there was so fun things started
getting popular no one with the small
flip phone it wasn't as prevalent now
because all you did on it was make phone
calls sure there wasn't texting and
video and Internet oh yeah it wasn't as
intrusive but my partner was more the
not gregarious he's nothing
he was a good opener he was a good
schmoozer so he did a lot of that if not
in any way compare our careers because
but just as an analogy Jerry Bruckheimer
and Don Simpson they're like but Simpson
was very much that kind of schmoozer an
idea guy and he'd go out he you know
sort of he was a good opener you know
and Jerry Bruckheimer was more is more
like the hands-on management day-to-day
you know get a done guy and I think that
was also Jesse and I had that same kind
of relationship so he would really go
out in mind the opportunities and then I
would come in and sit down and do
meetings when it was time to talk
logistics
so if jesse was out at a club and he met
a band he'd give him his business car
and hey we could do a video and then
they'd call him back and say hey we're
really excited to do that Jesse would
kind of schmooze a little bit on the
phone and then we would both go in maybe
go back to the club and meet with them
and I were talking about here's how I
think we can actually pull it off and
the more videos I did I'll guess it the
more confident I got doing that so I
really let Jesse open it and I think I
would close it with the execution here's
how we're gonna execute it how can you
do a video for five grand well here's
how we can do it we get great crew rates
we've got relationships with this and we
you know we can use short ends for the
film and doesn't not like all this kind
of stuff and I think okay I quit I start
to see how it can be done you know like
the two Steve's we were just talking
about the earlier Steve Jobs Steve
Wozniak so one had one set of duties the
other had the other and it worked right
they add two has the skills and yeah
they may I think just like like a
marriage you know it's two people that
can bring you know two different things
to the table and make each other better
in the process I think that's what you
know Jesse and I were able to do is two
complementary but different skills that
made us better as a whole
do you still read scripts I do I still
read scripts because I because I work as
a producer for my models a little bit
different so I left treasure in 2011 I
was ready for something different
treasure was a lot to do because
treasure Entertainment accompany I had
with Jessie was a lot because you're
running the company as a day-to-day sort
of executive but you're also producing
projects I also had management clients
because I was managing it was a lot to
do and you know it took up a lot of my
time and honestly you know I wanted
something different I want something
where I felt like I was being
compensated adequately for the amount of
time and skill I had accrued to that
point I said I think I can just do
better on my own
I'm just time to move on and try
something different but I also didn't
want to continue just chasing money and
trying to shop scripts and that sort of
thing and I said yeah I think I've built
up enough skill enough relationships and
resources and experience that I can
basically myself out as a producer
for hire I tell people I'm a I am
or in that you know people with a
project that's got some funding behind
it can come to me and I will look at the
script and I'm gonna be a lot less now
some people kind of like kill me for
attendance but maybe a lot less
discerning then I would if it was my
money if I'm looking to buy a script or
I have to shop it I can understand why a
lot of producers will pass if it's not
that one in one in a thousand script
that they've been looking for their past
past past because they're they're
putting their you know reputation out
there as they're trying to sell it and
get it made and they need to think they
you know they can they can raise money
for it I don't put that same level of
discernment when I read scripts when I
reuse good people are hiring me so it's
you know they hire me for development
services to help them get their script
in shape they can hire me for budgeting
services they can hire me for a business
plan or they can hire me to actually
produce the project because it's a job
for hire yes I'll read the script and as
long as it's not a complete piece of
garbage in my opinion I have had people
take take scripts maybe pay me to budget
and then say oh well you produce it I'll
say no they say why not I'm like I just
don't think it's a good script so I'll
tell them straight up there's the East
Coast thing we were talking about
earlier is I have no problem telling
people I think it's I think it's
horrible and I had a client that had
brought a script to me and had me budget
it and then asked me if I would use it
and I said oh no I might have been
producing it and he's like well what
would it need and I said I you we would
need to develop this whole script forms
from scratch I mean you you know you
have issues with your main characters
they you know they don't have any goals
they don't have any flaws there's no
central conflict I don't know who your
antagonist is the story's all over the
place it's just it's it's not shoot
ready even if you pay me I just wouldn't
be interested in doing it and he said
okay I'll start over with you let's go
through the development and we through
the whole budget out he had just hired
me to do and then he paid me to help
develop the script and then do a whole
new budget after a year and a half of
development on the script so for me I
get to tell people you know some people
say what's up that's a passion project I
want someone who's passionate I said
listen passion doesn't keep my lights on
once you've been doing this a lot long
enough you like making a living and
earning money doing what you're doing
but if I feel like the project's lacking
but I can but I feel like I can find my
passion as we work on it sometimes I
look at and I say you know but this guy
really liked working with them I see how
we can make this project better and I
know this person who's hiring me is open
to the creative development process
they're open to hearing out my ideas and
letting me whether it's an executive
producer whether it's a lot of time to
get hired by the writer director and
they have financing from somewhere but
they don't want to do that day to day
producing and so I'll come on is the
main producer or I'll come on as a
producer with them as long as I believe
that they're open to the creative
process and that I can read that script
and go I can I can get passionate about
this I can find my passion as we work on
it I don't need to be passionate from
the second I read it once I sign on the
dotted line you hire me and I'm involved
in producing this picture I'm a hundred
and ten percent into the picture it's
not you know I'm not so sure you're not
you're not passionate about it at first
once I put my name on the dotted line
that picture has my undivided attention
I'm gonna make it as great as I can be
as long as I see the potential for it to
be great and the potential for me to be
able to put my finger prints on it and
be able to find my passion as we work on
it yeah I'll you know I'll sign on to
that I'll sign on to that project so as
I see that potential
so my level discernments a little bit
different than somebody's happen to put
up their own money and go out and chase
me chase but it allows me to work on a
whole lot of other projects that I might
not have otherwise even known about and
then and also make a living doing it
which is nice when you can make a living
doing what you love
absolutely what if all the pieces are
there but the one thing is you sense
that one of the decision-makers is not
real flexible and you kind of have that
gut feeling going in or maybe there's
things that are telltale signs they're
they're not it's not an instinct you can
see it do you say no do you say well
okay I can kind of work around this
that's a great question because I just
had a phone call with a guy was
introduced to me and I could tell
talking to him that we wouldn't have
gotten on very well he comes from
outside the film world you know to me
seemed like a guy who thinks he knows
more than he does know and so you know I
like people who are going to bring me on
because I bring a certain skill set in
knowledge that they don't have and that
they're gonna listen to me and when it
comes to those sort of areas that I know
about they're gonna defer to me and I
don't feel like that's gonna be the case
it's probably not the best fit so even
if one of even if one of there's a
consortium of people and even if if I
fee like even one of them might be
problematic I'll pass I mean life's too
short at the end of the day I still want
to work with people that I want to work
with I've been fortunate and blessed
enough that nine times out of ten the
people I'm introduced to or you know
they're go getters they have a creative
vision they're excited about their
project and they're and they're open to
that creative process and I just I lay I
used to say is I like I just need three
things from you I need a script
I need your budget I need you to get the
hell out of my way half joking that's
the true meaning but let me do what I do
and so many the people that hire me they
are writers or directors or executive
producers that don't know enough about
filmmaking and that's exactly what they
want they said well I just want to
direct I know the story I want it but I
need a producer cannot come help me
realize this vision and I'll talk to
them about it and I'll say hey here's
here's a way I think we can do this and
here's what I think we can take what
you've done and make it even better and
elevate the material would you be
willing to do it and I'm like yeah okay
yeah that's actually great I can I can I
get that I get that sort of feeling from
them that
in those initial meetings that we'd work
great together and a lot of times they'd
hire me for a service and I tell them
you can hire me to develop your script
and hire me to budget it does not mean
I'm attached to your picture as a
producer but that's a good thing for me
because it also during that phase allows
me to feel them out and see throughout
that budgeting faith throughout the
development phase or the businessman or
whatever we're doing do I like working
with them do I like them as much as it's
not just them interviewing me it's me
interviewing them and usually by the
time we're done that process nine times
out of ten they're like you know if they
if they have the financing together
they're like I want you to produce this
let's let's go and I know by that point
as well whether I want to move forward
and like I said nine times out of ten
I'm like great let's do it
so over the course of the years it
sounds like you've honed that whether
it's a phrases that you've heard someone
say where you know yes this is gonna be
a working relationship or no I don't
think this is gonna work so you is it
much faster for you now you can kind of
know yeah right off the bat oh for sure
for sure it's much faster now knowing
whether I want to work with certain
people absolutely I mean and part of it
is just learning to trust your instincts
I mean I think when you're starting off
you're so hungry a lot of times you're
willing to ignore red flags but you know
as I've gone make I'm not desperate for
work I'm not you know I can be I can
still be somewhat you know somewhat
discerning if I want you know I just I
think you know you set your rules you
set your parameters you know I'm very
clear now with people in the nicest
possible way when people come to me like
I have this script and I need to raise
money and I'm like you know I don't show
up scripts I don't raise money here's
what I do do and once you have your
equity together you feel free to talk to
me if you want to bring me Ana's you
know for hire I work for you
so at the end of the day and let go
great and I've had people come back to
me and say hey I got my you know they
appreciate you being upfront sure but
yeah I've learned them to notice red
flags quick and if you know if I see a
couple of them like you know just like I
don't feel uncomfortable walking away
what five things does a screenplay have
to have for you to be interested in it
as a producer five things yeah what five
things I never thought about breaking it
down to five things
you know I think you know first and
foremost for me is the script just has
to be you know in my eyes but
well-written so it's got to be us like I
think a story that and I don't care what
the story is in terms of genre or you
know people ask me like you care you
know you care about certain genre and
there you've seen the work in all
different genres I said yeah because I
mean to me a good story transcends genre
it has nothing to do with genre genre is
just sort of a set of conventions that
allow people to identify what kind of
movie it is and and therefore whether
they want to see it or not but genre has
nothing to do with web you could tell
good story in any genre and to me
working in different genres part of the
excitement of working in this business
like that's why so many of us love being
this business right we don't go to the
same office necessary every day and we
can we're always pursuing something
different and so that the having
different genres to work in is great so
to me it's a well-told story like is
there some sort of character some sort
of protagonist can I identify with his
journey in some way I'm I'm gonna use
the word likeable I'm just gonna say is
it like a protagonist I can identify
with in some way I want to follow him
for some reason
you know is does he have goals does he
have flaws is there an antagonist that's
creating conflict with this guy and you
know a girl whatever the situation is
but is there there something I can get
behind and you know is there a is there
a strong theme like why are you telling
this story so I mean you know I think
just in terms of just being well-written
and then I would say number two is then
what's you know the budget range and
there's a budget range that's reasonable
so a lot of people they come to me and I
get a lot of how much would it cost to
do this script and I'm like well I'll
tell you what I'll answer that question
if you can answer a question for me how
long is a piece of string that's what I
like to ask them you can't just give me
a script how much does it cost to make
this was Matt Damon in your movie right
well your budget just went up by ten
million dollars I mean I can make an
argument to do this movie for a million
bucks or ten million bucks
so really it's more like how much can
you raise and then you know or or how
much do you have or you know if they if
they really don't have a good idea of
this who do you see in it how why do you
see it being distributed but I have to
get an idea of sort of what range and
how big they're seeing this in their
head and a lot of times I might read the
not a lot of times but sometimes I
migrated the script to get well that's
not gonna
that's not gonna happen on this you know
you're not gonna do avatar on a $500,000
budget or whatever so it has to be
doable you know for the for the for the
budget you know the end and beyond that
to just I guess logistically feasible so
you know for me to do I mean I you know
sometimes I look and I go yeah I mean
you know the budget the budgets okay
it's possible but I think for some other
logistical reason it would be very
challenging to pull this off even if
it's you know budget wise it can be done
you know there might be something else I
might see that that would make it that
would preclude it from being you know
oral actually actually at least allowing
me to do it effectively for whatever
that reason is but I think those are
really the two main main things that I
look for is just you know is the budget
reasonable for the for the script and is
the script you know well-written and
beyond that and do I like working with
this person do I you know do I get a
good good sense because you're gonna
spend a year or more dealing with this
person depending on the scope of my
duties so you know sometimes I'm just
literally brought on to there's no
development I'm like okay the scripts
decent you know and I think I can
influence it enough through the
production process to make it a good a
good picture and then at post when I
deliver the master drive or the DCP or
whatever the final deliverable is I'm
done I'm not involved to mark in your
distribution there are projects like
that it just depends on the term of the
contract so but I would say at the least
I'm spending at least a year with this
person so so yeah well-written script
reasonable budget and logistics and and
I like the person those are really my
main criteria I don't like if you get to
five I don't yeah
I get there could be like sub there
could be sub factors within there but
those are sort of the broad scope
factors I noticed you said something
about going to a day job and I just want
to ask you about that did you ever try a
day job and and how did you know it
wasn't for you and how did you know you
liked the not uncertainty but the the
variation
yeah that's producing I did I did I did
have day jobs makes my first job with my
old producing partner Jesse was with
I worked for Bobby Neumayer who produced
the quinta the quintessential indie film
movie that started the entire movement
as we know it's like indie film as we
know today
Bobby produced the movie that started it
all which is Sex Lies and videotape like
an 89 right si that was the one what
pulp fiction clerks or any of those I
mean that was like the one I mean there
were indie movies before they're like
black blood simple and sup but they
didn't kick off the movement the way Sex
Lies did like that was like this whole
groundbreaking thing that inspired
filmmakers like hey we can do this and
so he was a great mentor and so I worked
for him as an assistant and so my old
producing partner Jesse was also we were
both his assistants so day job working
for Bobby we were working on training
day on a movie training day and on
another movie called national security
with Martin Lawrence and Steve Zahn it
was a comedy like buddy right kind of
cub and then Santa Claus too we had in
development so Bobby was very prolific
and then at night that's when we were
like hitting up bands and shooting
videos on weekends and things so you
know I worked for him throughout 2002
like the beginning of 2001 I got into
UCLA at so I mean I couldn't be an
assistant and because the hours are just
- especially for a cupcake producer but
I but I learned a lot about the studio
system working for Bob because he had
deals with Warner Brothers and
intermedia and so it was a good you know
it was a good learning experience I was
just starting off and then I had the
luxury of not having to work a day job
throughout school because I was living
on school loans when I was at UCLA and
the classes were at night so I could
work on building my business in the day
and go to school at night but when I got
out of school it was like you know maybe
we hadn't gotten to the point where I
could live on live on the money yet so I
got a job working for a trailer house as
an assistant called open road and
they're owned by a company called New
Wave in Burbank New Wave Entertainment's
a pretty big company and I kind of
transitions up up through the ranks in
new wave and became a supervisor for the
print department so we did all the
posters for like we did like Borah and
fantastic for like ed did we have done a
lot of you know Simpsons and stuff
Fox stuff and so I was doing music
videos and commercials and some Emmy
feature stuff while I was also working
that day job up until about 7:00 and
that's when I was able to I was at a
point where I could
finally kind of go full-time and like
eke out a living and yeah and so for the
next four years I mean I was full-time
treasurer entertainment until I left
yeah that was good yeah do you think
it's a mistake for a filmmaker to think
about distribution and marketing after
yes I absolutely 100% think it is a
mistake to only start thinking about
marketing distribution after the film is
done I and again I'm gonna say more
things that are gonna piss people off is
I really think the film schools have it
all wrong and you know I mentioned that
guy that I spoke with recently who I
just didn't feel like I would get along
with and he's one of these guys that
like just doing it for the passion and
then I yeah I explained to him you know
there's a reason we call it show
business and not show show and I stole
that from Peter Guber by the way was one
of my professors at UCLA and he used to
say this there's it's not show show it's
show business if you just want to go out
and make a piece of art for yourself and
you have the money to blow you know go
ahead but that doesn't mean you're gonna
be part of the entertainment industry
that doesn't mean you're a be part of
the film business it is a business it is
a commodity as well as art that's where
people get hung up as well it's art
right it's art but it's also a commodity
and the people sacrifice one for the
other I read an article the other day it
was a couple months ago that just oh my
god my I was like a cartoon my have said
I was so I was so annoyed with this
article it's it's it just started with
okay now you've finished your film now
let's not start time to start thinking
about distribution I'm like no thinking
about distribution ages ago from the
script stage you should have been
thinking about distribution and I've
told you know I've told film because
I've worked with the smart way to do it
I mean they always have to skip that
they just really want to do and I'm like
well have you considered your audience
if you consider whether there's an
audience for it have you considered how
you're gonna get to that audience have
you considered you know what how big
that audience is and whether it
justifies the budget you want to you
want to spend at cetera etc time you
have you have you looked at the market
how many other films just like it around
the market how oversaturated that is I
don't know how many times I've heard
people say I'm gonna do horror because
it's so cheap so you can make a bunch of
money on but you're only considering one
thing you're on considering budget
you're not considering drawbacks of
horror
like the fact that when you go to AFM
there's 18 other films with posters and
all look exactly like yours all
competing for that same shelf space or
that same distributor when we has a
budget to acquire so many films you're
not considering the fact that a lot of
name talent doesn't like to do horror
which I was up against on my latest film
the basement was it was tough the even
casting directors know that and a lot of
casting directors don't want to touch
war because they know a lot of name
actors just avoid horror movies which is
why so many times you see horror movies
most of the time is like nobody in it
that you really recognize unless there's
a really smart different sort of horror
you know maybe you see some people take
a chance on it but you know they're not
necessarily looking at it like a
business I tell people there's there's
no other industry in which you would
spend millions and millions and millions
of dollars like on Rd and develop you
know developing like widgets and mass
producing widgets I'm gonna set up a big
manufacturing space big warehouse I'm
gonna make widgets and I've got this
whole staff of people boxing up widgets
and then when I'm done I have this huge
warehouse of widgets and I'm like
alright now let me figure out how I can
sell these you know you identify a need
in the market like hey this people are
renting or buying these kind of movies
and you know right there you know
there's definitely a an opportunity here
and I have a great story I think I can
tell within that and consulting with
distributors and sales agents who know
the marketplace and if you know if you
don't want if you're afraid to get the
distributors and sales agents involved
early and find out what the market looks
like and what kind of what buyers are
looking for and what budget ranges those
pictures are in and which ones are
making my if you don't want to do that
and then you make a picture and you make
no money you know you really don't have
anyone to blame but yourself
it's it's absolutely the end-use and the
marketing the distribution distribution
and publicity festivals all you should
be looking at that from the beginning
from from inception of your story and so
yeah I mean a lot of times it falls on
deaf ears but I always advise the
filmmaker so we should get distributors
and sales agents involved from the
get-go
I'm not saying it's gonna make it's
gonna make it foolproof that you're
gonna get a return on your investment
because that but it's going to I think
get you a lot closer I think
are they always right now there I mean
they can be wrong as well but they know
a lot more than we do
just like you trust a DP to shoot the
picture because he knows more about
lighting and camera than you do or an
editor because he knows a lot more about
cutting than you do distribution sales
agents know more about selling in the
market than you do and so if you want a
better chance at getting some sort of
return involve people that know more
about what they do then you do about
what they do and I say this all the time
when I hire people I said look I hired
you because you know more about what you
do than I know about what you do so I'm
gonna tell you the result I want I'm
gonna tell you when I want to buy I'm
gonna tell you what resources I'm gonna
give you to get me that result and if
you say yeah I can do it I'm gonna say
great go do it then and I'm here to
support you you tell me hey you know I
you know I just I need you to do this or
that as long as it's within those
parameters done if there's a problem
we'll fix it you know and we'll make
sure it doesn't happen again
so you know trust but verify but I don't
stand over their shoulders you know
making sure I fired you because this is
what you do and you're better at it than
I am so go do it and the crew loves that
and you should the sales agents and the
distributors treat them like part of
your team
because by the time people have made
their movie and come to the distributors
the distributors are like well there's
not much we can do that now you could
try to craft a marketing campaign but
worse it way if you had this person in
if you would only spent this much and if
you had done these things with the story
we'd be in a lot better of a position
now all we have we didn't have any say
in the story or script we didn't have a
say in the casting we have any say in
the budget now all we have is the
marketing campaign but we're stuck with
the movie we have there's not much we
can do with it now so I am absolutely a
fan of of people getting distributors
and sales agents or talking to producers
reps whoever you can that knows the mark
place get them involved as early as
possible do you remember your first film
market like what that was like like
walking around whether it was AFM or
something I mean just just surprises
things that you were kind of shocked by
yeah I think it was AFM actually it was
probably the first one I'd ever gone to
and yeah
I mean I really didn't know what to
expect you know you walk in because it's
held in Santa Monica in the lemare ago
kind of a like right next italo's I
guess in the main one but and that sort
of spills over into like you know sort
of outside areas and things but I do
remember cuz I remember parking and
being there for a meeting and then
coming out a couple hours later and them
charging me like $80
are you insane Santa Monica yeah I was
like this is insane and I think next
time I parked at the beach for 20 bucks
and just saw I was like I mean it's like
not like it's just to me it's something
I value feeling like am I seriously
wasting that much money on parking
that's really coming from Philadelphia
where you could park anywhere and not
pay so I remember that and then you know
the food and drinks are outrageous but I
think the afm from me was probably um it
was a little eye-opening but also I
didn't feel like I got personally a huge
amount of value out of it because a lot
of people are meeting with where people
that live in LA and so I didn't I didn't
at the first well I didn't really get an
opportunity to meet a lot of I was
meeting with people who who were based
here like how am i paying eighty books
are parking in sixty bucks for a
sandwich and a drink or whatever to meet
with people I can just set up meetings
with after AFM so you know in subsequent
years I wanted to make sure if I was
gonna go to AFM I would only go if I
really had some specific reason to be
there picture I was where I was working
on or meetings with people from out of
town that I couldn't otherwise meet with
and not one on video big on video calls
like if I'm gonna get all ready and comb
the hair and get all you know it's
because I'm going out I don't want to
have to do that just for a video calling
me half the time when I'm talking on the
phone I gotta look like I look like a
complete slob so I don't want to just to
do a phone call I don't want to get all
so I was going to the AFM for in
subsequent years to actually meet people
that I didn't have the opportunity to
interact with face to face and and more
specifically if I had a project and a
reason I needed to be there because a
lot of times you know have a sales agent
or I have a rep that's there and there's
no reason to buy $2,000 badges to go up
in the Suites if I have a team they're
like you know you don't need me to go up
in the Suites you know with you so the
AFM is is it's good it's it's good for
what it's for which is you know buyers
and sellers to interact and to negotiate
and discuss deals from sort of a top
level and then they can do that
you know you can do this sort of nuanced
stuff later but sort of just you know
getting face time generating rapport
check out these materials it's good for
the buyers and sellers to come together
a lot of times I don't need to be
directly there I give my rep whoever
selling my picture I tell them you know
here's here's what I want out of it and
then again let them go do what they're
good at what does the filmmaker able to
get business cards so maybe they can
kind of like you can gauge a lot just by
like watching two people talk and you
can kind of gauge the feel so is that
something you can do is just get
business cards for when yeah I mean I
guess you could I you know I I guess I
don't go there that often just to get
business cards I mean you know if I'm
there anyway sure I really don't find it
that challenging to meet people from
even all around the world because
projects that I am working on I'm
constantly meeting new people constantly
getting introduced to new people and
then through social media I mean
LinkedIn and Facebook and you know in my
own website me acosta have people from
all around the world whether it's could
be a DP in in England it could be a
visual effects company in India
it could be somebody who just moved here
from Australia and hey I'm an you know
di T and I whatever I feel like I just
through the course of my business and
through social media I meet so many
people that I don't need to drive down
to Santa Monica and pay 80 bucks to get
business cards just doesn't the world's
becoming so interconnected nowadays
anyway you know and if you don't have
somebody to fit a certain position it's
so easy to to find those people now I'm
looking at possibly shooting a picture
in Australia I reached out to film
Australia's LA office and next thing I
know I mean and Michelle Sandoval there
is fantastic she's the point person and
she and she have in charge of the
operation there and she started
introducing me to you know hey yeah I've
got a guy in Australia he does you know
he does this that in the other they do
debt financing in Australia oh and this
guy you know I can you know introduce
you a upm in Queensland and you know
next thing I know I'm emailing and
chatting with a upm in Queensland I mean
it's just so you know do I need to go to
to do that I don't think I really do
forgive my naivete but why does name
talent not want to do horror is the
budget too low or is there a stigma
attached I think it's I think named
talent is probably more averse to horror
because of a stigma I don't think it has
to do because I mean some horror
pictures have decent budgets and I mean
you you you could be going after I'd be
going after maybe the same names I'd be
going after if it was a romance or
comedy on that same budget level so I
don't think it's the money I I do think
it's more the stigma I had several my
horror picture had several casting
directors pass we had trouble finding a
cat we were willing to pay them you know
decent you know a decent salary and a
lot of them just didn't want to take it
and I think because they felt like it
was gonna be tough to get even even a
moderate modest names on board you know
a horror movie that was you know it's
not it's not like seven where it's like
this cuz smart thriller with some kind
of really pseudo risk elements
it's like straight horror it's a tough
sell and I think a lot of actors don't
feel like maybe if they're already
established that they need to do that
genre that it's gonna help elevate their
career they want to do more serious work
or you know whatever whatever that might
be
I'm not saying I agree with that I think
our picture of the basement I thought I
had a really unique interesting
storyline very that's great kind of
psychological or had some gruesome
moments but I think those gruesome
moments were enough to like sort of
scare people away so yeah I think that's
stigma you know could be the managers
telling them look you don't want to do
horror because maybe even if it's not
the stickers that sting was our real
perception is reality so if it's
perceived enough to be there then
they're just like better steer clear
you're getting offers on these other you
know dramas romantic comedies action
pictures do those because there is no
stigma with those we'll go ahead they're
safe that's my you know assessment and I
don't know if that's a hard person
accurate but from what I've seen that's
definitely actors avoiding horror
pictures you know outside of big studio
ones or is definitely real because I've
experienced it firsthand but that would
be my assessment on why twelve questions
every screenwriter has to be able to
answer about their screenplay the 12
questions or the 12 questions yeah so I
told I mentioned earlier I was a manager
a literary manager so when I only did
writers and directors for about eight
years and so I had I'm gonna give him
egg Lefou who I mentioned earlier Joey
Joey fosters producing partner was a
great influence I mean she had the
series of questions and it might have
been eight or ten to get us thinking
about the story we wanted to tell and so
when I started managing I started to
those questions and you know expand them
a little bit re-appropriated and I'm a
little bit like I came up with twelve
and so every time I had a writer come to
me with with a story that they were
working on it could have been you know
it could have been the synopsis phase or
the treatment phase or could have been a
finished script but I had a lot of
problems I'd say okay let's rewind and
let's go back to the fundamentals or
even if they just had an idea but they
hadn't written anything yet
take a look these questions can you
answer these questions and you know the
questions are are things like what's the
genre is its studio or independent who's
your protagonist what's their goal with
their flaw who's the main relationship
what's driving this story who's your
audience who's the antagonist what's
their goal in their flaw you know what's
the narrative question driving the film
so like every story you should be able
to sum it up in one main question like
so like dial if I was diehard would be
like you know will you know New York cop
trapped you know will this New York cop
free his wife and hostages from some
European terrorists who have them
trapped in skyscrapers like it's like
one question right like so what's your
narrative question driving this story
and what's your theme and what's your
theme attic question like what's why are
you telling us that the ematic question
is like the question you posed to the
audience it could be a moral question it
could be or something else but some
question you want them to think about
like it is family really just people
you're related to or is it something
more you know it could be a fee Matic
question it's it's not overtly stated in
the story but it's kind of like in the
film sub
just it's like what you know the film is
really kind of about and then your theme
is how you answer that question by the
end that's your theme or your story so
like what are those things and I might
even be missing a couple ayat but off
the top of my head those are like a lot
of and if you can't answer those
questions or if those questions don't
make sense together
a lot of times there's the problems with
the story so for example if you say your
protagonist goal is my protagonist goal
is to grab the banana and what's your
antagonist goal to grab the orange well
they're in two different movies they're
never going to intersect there's no
conflict great your protagonist grabs
the banana and your antagonist grabs the
orange movies over and that's a very
simplistic example but those are the
kind of things but on a deeper level we
look at my goal wall here there's a few
things that aren't making sense you say
your main relationship is character and
character baby your antagonist character
see if I even and meet in your main
relationship that's moving the story
forward so why are they why are they
your antagonist so the 12 questions from
and this is from amateur writers who
have never had anything sold what I you
know called development cases people
that you're you have a belief in because
they're talented you're trying to get
them there all the way up to you know
experienced screenwriters who have had
you know a half dozen pictures produce
you know the the 12 questions is a great
sort of reset okay let me square away I
mean you know even if I've done this a
hundred times every story is different
in a lot of times you miss those those
important details and once I think that
12 questions are are making sense now
and things are tying together like oh
now see how the protagonist goal ties
into your theme okay now everything
starts puzzle pieces start making sense
then I say okay now now let's work out a
synopsis three or four paragraphs you
know first exit connect third act or
whatever just so we can say okay now
let's make sure from just a broad story
standpoint that all those questions are
being addressed and then from there you
can expand it to a full treatment scene
outline and it's then you start writing
your script cuz like I explained to them
a lot easier to develop the story in a
synopsis form or a treatment form than
it is to keep rewriting the script when
there's fundamental problems in it you
don't start building the building it's
slanted I don't start taking out some
bricks and try to get you you work all
of that out on the design phase and the
blueprint phase and so that's what I try
to get them to doing it and the 12
questions is to me is like okay that's
that beginning that
that organic seed that we need to plant
to make a healthy tree grow and when
presented with those 10 questions or
whatever it is
do most screenwriters see the vague
areas of their of their story or are a
lot of them very sort of stuck on those
ideas and they they it makes sense to
them but they're not willing to waver no
I I find that they're usually very very
open you know I mean again it's not
gonna be open to the process you know to
the creative development process there
I'm you know they're not gonna be I'm
not gonna be able to do much with them
I'm young I think most of them they're
coming to because they know there's
something wrong you know if they think
it's great then hey whatever if I read
the script I go yeah okay yeah this is
decent I'll go with it and we might
bring you know I have them or bring
another writer writer in to do polishes
or something but you know most of the
time when they when they come to me to
develop the script to work with them
they know something's wrong so that's
why I said well let's go back to those
fundamentals and I don't necessarily
answer the questions for them I just
sometimes I mean sometimes I can I'll
come up with ideas and say well maybe
when I was reading your story I felt
like your theme was a little more about
this I called yeah yeah yeah okay
sometimes I can articulate or pull up
pull out what they were trying to get to
quicker than they can but a lot of times
it's just me pointing out discrepancies
like you know you say you know that you
want to do sort of you know this this
and this which you know makes it feel
like you want it's very small and this
and that but you also say you want to do
a studio picture but is that what
studios are buying is that what studios
are putting out now I might just call
out some discrepancies and they call
yeah okay you're right maybe this is
more in the air and we discuss it we
talk about it but I think getting on the
same page getting getting those things
so they're making sense makes all of the
rest of the stuff month much much easier
so I don't get a lot of pushback I don't
get a lot of pushback because a lot of
it's coming from them just me pointing
out guiding them most independent
filmmakers do they feel they can compete
with Hollywood or do you think they
realize like no matter how great this
passion project is or this coming-of-age
drama or whatever it's never going to be
able to compete it's a it's the rare gem
that transcends
that somehow is discovered and and has a
life of its own let me ask you when you
say compete you mean compete with Studio
pictures or compete with Indies that
have gained a lot of notoriety or yeah
this you know there because there is
this like indie sort of world but the
world of it is is like in this million
dollar range which doesn't feel really
indie to most quote-unquote new indie
filmmakers so do you think that a lot of
indie filmmakers that are doing this
whether they're crowdfunding whether
they're using family money and it's a
very small budget realize that it's
gonna be very difficult or maybe it's
not if the story catches on to the sort
of upper echelon indie I don't think
nothing a lot of the filmmakers I deal
with even think that far ahead or if
they do they don't express it to me
i angle um are so focused on their
project that they're not necessarily
thinking about how it will do in the
marketplace and that's what I'm trying
to get them to think more about so some
of them who do have an overinflated
sense of I think what it can do in the
market and I try to temper that a bit
you know I had a great experience
working with William Lew who directed
comfort and comfort was one of the
lowest but you want talk about real
indium it was one of it was like the
second I think it was like the second
lowest budgeted narrative picture I'd
ever done not including Doc's
documentary or like new media stuff but
just in terms of like feature films ii
like the second lowest budget i'd ever
done and I read the script I was like
wasn't that excited about it when I
first read the script I'm like me but I
saw enough in it that okay like I think
with the right execution I could do
something with this and that brought
another writer in to help polish the
script with will to know cut down a lot
of the chatty chatty dialogue you over
written dialogue and things but where
will was really really good
was in listening to others and like I
say like you know these people are on
board because they're better at what
they do then you are at what they do and
let your cinematographer take your
vision and let him you know figure out
how to shoot it you say I want this shot
and I want it blue okay let him figure
out how to do that shot make it blue and
then move you know move on and talk to
the actors and if the actors have ideas
and let them play around let them try
stuff I he was willing to
experiment a little bit he was willing
to listen other people's ideas and it
made that picture so much better than I
think it could have been just on the
page from what you know what you read on
the page but when we started working on
this you know I was like well let me see
so it's a drama it's starring you know
two kids Chinese American kids and no
one's ever heard of you have no name
stars in this we have a very small
limited production budget PA and
marketing is probably going to be even
more anemic than that I said you're not
gonna make one dime on this movie I just
want you to know that you're gonna make
no money zero
you won't make anything music okay I
just want to do it anyway
as long as you understand that you know
you're doing it for yourself for the
story you just need to tell for the art
or whatever but it's not gonna be
anything more than that and now in the
back of my head as a producer I want it
to be more than that but I wanted to set
those that bar where I felt like it was
even a little bit below realistic just
so to make sure you're on the same page
and the film turned out I was one of the
films that like most proud of even
though again budget really had nothing
to do with it I think wills
understanding of story and how and his
ability to execute to listen to others
and take the best ideas as a director
and he was just a great collaborative
partner made that film what it was and
and we sold it to a number of different
territories and it continues to make
money when he make out his first check I
was like congratulations I was wrong to
be made Lord then you made more than
nothing congratulations and yeah I think
that's sort of a testament to you know
to the process and to his willingness to
be to be open to the creative process
but I try to get filmmakers thinking
about it from a business standpoint and
tempering any sort of unrealistic
expectations I think it's a big you know
especially when they're not willing to
involve sales agents or distributors or
other people who know the marketplace
when they just want to do the project
they want to do I want to look at
sometimes you might get a script and say
well yeah I think with the right casting
if we can keep it to this budget level I
do believe it can do pretty well based
on what I've seen still not going to be
as knowledgeable as the guys who are
selling and buying every day
but I you know I can I have some sense I
think just being working in the industry
and constantly speaking to those people
about you know okay what's doing well
and you know you want to do this kind of
picture with the right cast and yeah I
think this could do this could do pretty
well but yeah i think i think managing
expectations is a big part of the indie
world these guys that come in with these
pipe dream kind of you know they're
gonna expect the stars you know the son
of the moon you know you have to you
have to rein that in a little bit better
i think it's better to under promise and
over deliver than the other way around
that's a great story
have you ever optioned or bought a
screenplay III have options in both
screenplays yeah under treasurer
entertainment oh okay for I went
freelance I yeah we used to all the time
and a lot of them came from our clients
as well key take us through the process
sorry yeah uh so you know in terms of at
least when you know in Treasure
entertainment when we would part of what
I liked about managing clients is you
had this in-house table of talent that
you could draw from so if we had
identified something in the market you
know an opportunity or so you know for
some reason we wanted to do a certain
type of picture I you know had clients
in-house I said hey what about one of
these ideas because this is something
that we're thinking about doing if we
can develop this with you and get it to
the point where I think it's strong
maybe we'll option it from you guys or
well well you know we'll buy it so not
to say we didn't shop around but it kind
of allowed us to just get exactly what
we wanted working with the writer and
then getting it to okay this movie one
okaywell option it now as opposed to
scouring the marketplace trying to find
that exact kind of thing we wanted but
yeah I mean once once we identified a
strong project either something that we
came across or something that we had a
client create with our help
the optioning process was you know
pretty simple I mean you know a lot of
times we just do you know one-year
option with with a you know when you're
renewal period and you know whatever
sort of modicum of depending on the size
of the film mean options can be we could
pay anything from a dollar just to you
know if it's you know real development
writer and they're like
look I just want to get it out there and
it's like alright let's just see if we
can get this thing out here we're
putting our sweat equity into it so it
might just be a $1 you have to have
something called consideration there has
to be something from this side going to
the side to make it legal and even if
that's a dollar here's a dollar here's
your script and an option is just
basically saying you know you can't sell
it to anyone else
during this beer we have the exclusive
right to chop it to set it up or to buy
it during this period and if we exercise
the option here will give you $10,000
$20,000 whatever whatever the amount is
and then the option is exercised so it
gives us the option to buy it
exclusively for that period or we might
have options things up to on a thousand
bucks or two thousand bucks I mean just
depending on the size of the project it
was all indie stuff so you know I mean
we're getting $10,000 options but you
know a 500 bucks or whatever it is and
then that applies against the purchase
price so if you option something for 500
bucks and you're gonna buy this kit for
20 grand that 500 is typically applied
against the 20 so you pay the 19 5 if
you decide to buy it although those
deals can be structured however you know
however you want so yeah I think that
was that's kind of how how we approached
it was hey in-house talent awesome and
because we were their managers and they
saw all the sweat equity we were putting
into trying to get their career off the
ground and the project a lot of times we
could option a script for a lot less
than if we had just found it and they
didn't know well something like well I
want three thousand dollars for this you
know we had already built this
relationship and and so it was a good
you know it was a good system and worked
for us what about life story rights yeah
I'm working on a project right now
actually called walking on Paul meadows
with yeah writer Jim Castel and Ed Asner
who knows like screen legend good old
Edie and the story is based on a
real-life person Myles Richards who's
very actively involved in the project as
well as an executive producer and he had
met Jim many years ago through a mutual
friend and Jim found this guy's story so
interesting he sat down he interviewed
him like a tape recorder for
hours I mean I don't know who's like
maybe a couple days worth of interviews
but they you know he got all he's like
wow this guy's story is so interesting
and decided you know this is the kind of
story that that would make a great at
first I think he was thinking about a TV
show but then he decided to let me make
this into uh a script a feature script
and I got involved when Jim came to me
and asked me to do a budget and it's a
pretty fairly large picture I would say
it's like almost maybe even studio
mid-level kind of budget and I got you
know did the budget and he and Jim was
very happy with the work and decide a
smiie if I would come on and as a
producer and work with work with him on
it and I I you know I came on board and
I asked him I said you have the miles
life rights this guy miles extraordinary
you know kind of human being he was he
was actually a marijuana smuggler and
had started when he was like 21 or
something in smugglers first like you
know batch of marijuana from Jamaica he
was working on the Playboy Club his
father his father in the construction
coming I was building the Playboy Club
in Jamaica and he went there for a
summer to work on it and that's where he
got involved in marijuana and started
smuggling it and his first load when he
was like 21 even me like a quarter
million dollars there's in the sixties
oh wow
and so right so the thing about Myles
was he never did a load the same way
twice he always is always some
innovative way and this script goes the
story goes into a couple of these I mean
there's so many different ways but but
like he sank a ship off the coast of
Florida on purpose loaded with water
sealed bags of marijuana filed for a
permit to do a salvage operation so the
Coast Guard got to know him and then
every you know their salvaging bringing
up parts of the boat with you know
marijuana in it and the Coast Guard's
like right there and they had no idea he
came with these ingenious
so it took the DEA like 15 years to even
know who he was another five years to
catch him and you know it's very much
catch me if you can
Goodfellas like that tonally like the
likeable criminal shouldn't follow over
a wolf a wall so you follow over 20
years of their life kind of that kind of
arc and they're come up
and sort of you know the sort of life
trajectory as miles did go to prison he
was there for 11 years he was in
solitary confinement for four years came
out a very different person then he
started a whole legal business and
construction became a millionaire
illegally but it was a really
interesting story and I asked you have
Myles life rights for this and he didn't
I said well that's the first thing we
need to do and so you know we we went to
Myles and at that point we had already
worked with him long enough that he knew
us and trusted us I mean I had talked to
him on the phone I've never met him
personally but I talked him on the phone
Jim had you know been dealing with him
for years
and so I had a life rights option
drafted up and you know Myles signed off
on it I mean we had certain agreements
with him that we wouldn't while we can
take creative license that there were
certain things we wouldn't do Myles want
to make sure the smuggling was depicted
realistically it's like look just don't
have anybody running around with a
suitcase of a million dollars that looks
like this he's I know what a million
dollars looks like in a suitcase of
fifteen hundred dollar bills and it's
not like what they look like into these
movies where it's you know these big
suitcases stacked to the brim with
hundreds and he's like that's not what a
million like there's stuff like he
wanted us to stay true to a lot of the
aspects even if we took creative license
with let's say some of the FBI guys that
were chasing him or his lawyers in the
script there's one main lawyer that sort
of deals that deals with his case but
he's an amalgamation of many lawyers in
real life there was many lawyers it
wasn't this one guy so things like that
were okay but he wanted to make sure the
smuggling was was treated accurately and
so you know we agreed to the things that
he wanted and yeah he signed off on that
life rights option it really gave most
creative control of the project and and
the ability to sort of take this take
the story within those bounds within
those parameters where we wanted to and
so just as an option expires then
someone's life rights expire as well and
then they're free to use them with
another production company could we have
it and so that we have a certain term
and then it automatically renews for
extended periods unless one of us
cancels it so long as the miles is happy
I mean it's gonna keep renewing unless
he gives us written notice
within you know 30 days of when the
expiration is fascinating yeah yeah and
when does that come out by the way well
we're working we're working toward
trying to get it off the ground for top
of 2019 in terms of production so this
is this is I mentioned earlier project
we were looking at possibly shooting in
Australia there's may be some tax
incentives we can take advantage of plus
a lot of the picture takes place in
Southern California and the Caribbean
and so Australia has locations that can
really play for both because the
Caribbean really looks very different
than Southern California
you know Caribbean is very flat white
sands different types of palm trees
different type of water just a different
outlook that the people I mean it's very
different but yet Australia I think has
options for us that can play for both so
that's something we've been looking at
how does a movie producer view a
screenplay versus how an actor filmmaker
or writer views the screenplay I think
well I mean since I'm not an actor or
you know some of these other people I
can't I can't as I speak to their
process but I mean I think a producer
probably is a lot more comprehensive in
terms of when I look at a script I'm
thinking about a lot of different I'm
thinking about all those things it's
specifically how how they relate budget
wise and fiscally but also you know how
that hmm you know the creative and the
fiscal will work together so you know
when I read the script I'm thinking
about story and I'm thinking about the
arc of the characters and I'm thinking
about if conflict I don't think about
why are we telling this story but I'm
also thinking okay who would I get to
play these okay I get to play these
roles on this budget level like what are
some decent names who am i picturing in
this you know I'm thinking about and if
I mean I'm presuming in this situation
that the movie's real that's not just a
script I'm not just reading it for fun
but it's like okay we're making this
picture like this pictures funded mark
read the script so I'm reading and I'm
like okay how we gonna pull off that we
need that this kind of grandiose house
or there's a good example would be
there's a project I'm working on right
now called ly2 and very hopeful oh we'll
shoot this summer the financing is
getting locked down
as we speak and a very cool thriller
about these sort of two and we come like
helicopter parents these sort of like
wealthy parents they've got these two
ten-year-old twins and the twins are
they're kinda like they're the parents
are find them hard to tutor and at the
point the big the boys got like a
learning disability and the girls kind
of too smart for her own good too
rebellious and they're having trouble
tutoring these kids in it and the kids
have their own language that they speak
in when they don't want the parents to
know what they're saying so the parents
buy this device called Ali - it's kind
of like a an Alexa or a Google home
device like many smart devices
you know connects to the house it can
lock the door can open the windows it
can do all these kind of turn the lights
down and answer questions whatever and
it starts at first the kids don't like
it but then it starts learning their
language and it befriends them and then
it and then the kids start liking it and
they starts you know that they start it
starts tutoring you know the kids better
than the parents can and eventually the
kids start pushing back on the parents a
little bit it starts overstepping its
bounds and the parents are finally like
we need to get rid of this thing at
first it's good but then it starts to
take take it a little bit over the line
and by this point the kids like love
this thing so much that they secretly
get another one without the parents
knowing and it remembers them like his
mind is in the cloud like it remembers
these two kids and the parents decide
we're gonna send the kids to two
different private schools instead of
together and the kids are like freaking
out because they don't want their twins
they don't want to be separated so the
ly2 starts planning with the kids to
take out the parents it starts plotting
with them to get rid of the parents and
it controls the house and it locks the
door you can you know so this whole big
it builds to this really big climax and
it's just a really really well-written
script so I'm using that as an example
because when I'm reading the script and
it looks like you know this is moving
toward production I'm looking at this
I'm going okay this house is such a
major location we need to be able to
it's like a character they'll lead to
the voice of the lead - what does it
look like the lights on it it glows or
whatever is that gonna be a practical
effect is that gonna be a post visual
effect how are we gonna pull that off
the casting so you've got the two
parents you've also got the kids when
are we gonna shoot this thing because
with kids you can only shoot so many
hours so with their age group maybe you
get nine now
a day with them if it's during a school
year you can always shoot for say six of
those hours and the other three they're
having to be schooled
yeah the set teacher has to be schooling
them but if it's in the summer when
school is not in as long as the set
teachers on set we don't have to burn
shooting time with schooling so okay you
know summer is probably a better time to
shoot it so I'm giving you some examples
but yeah production design in the house
I'm looking at some of these things and
I'm saying you know okay we need this
and we need we need to dress the kids
room like this okay you know there's a
very specific style do I know somebody
who might be able to execute that style
it's very postmodern I've worked with a
production designer that did this and
Wow sound is such a big deal I know some
thinking about all these all of these
things as I'm reading it as opposed to
and actors reading it yes they're
considering story I think everybody with
some sort of creative you know position
is thinking about story to some degree
but actor is gonna be much more focused
on their role in the arc of their role
and the Scimitar covers gonna be much
more focused they're gonna be reading
and seeing something totally different
they're gonna say oh wow okay so you got
a bunch of exterior night out here by
the pool we're gonna light the pool how
are we gonna light I'm gonna light the
water how we gonna they're gonna be
looking at that way I see you got the
shot that follows them through the house
and so they're gonna want to talk to the
director about how that I'm thinking
about all that stuff that I'm thinking
about like okay doing we're gonna have
the budget for those kind of lights and
creatively if we can't pull something
off how are we gonna be able to you know
to make that we can't pull that off with
the budget or or there's some other
logistical circumstance that's gonna
make that unreasonable what are we gonna
have to change in the script to do that
and I'm also a line producer at upm so I
am I'm breaking down the script I am
thinking about all of these things okay
we need Steadicam to pull that off and
we need so I really do get down to that
level of detail but it to some degree
but I I'm thinking about everything you
know in one form or fashion as it rates
to creative and fiscal and how those two
things work together and I think I think
probably a lot of other I think writers
are probably focused more on story and
not a lot of not necessarily on the
logistics so when I talk to them I'm
like but how are we gonna pull this off
you know yeah well so from a producer
producers perspective we're talking were
thinking more about execution well I
think a lot of writers just they just
tell the story they want to tell and
they don't necessarily think about how
we done which is
fine you're the writer that's your job
just get the story out but when it
starts to become real and then we have
to start approaching how we're gonna do
it sometimes some things for logistical
reasons have to have to shift do you
think a lot of new writers don't see
that just yet like you really have to
once someone's been in the game for a
while they can really scale things back
to one room one town you know I find the
people that the writers that grasp it
the quickest are - it's who have also
produced or who have been involved in
something other than I mean a lot of
times you know writers they like locking
themselves in a way in a room and just
working by themselves they haven't
necessarily been part of the
collaborative creative process but the
ones who have the ones who have also
director also produced and understand
the exigencies of production I think
those people have a better grasp when I
say this is gonna be tough to do here
are some ways we might be able to do it
you know as an example I just recently
budgeted a script called not long
together I think it's fantastic
and there was a scene in it you know one
bigger scene where the guy shows up and
it's a big woman has died and there's
ambulances and cop cars and there's a
helicopter with a spotlight because
they're looking in the water and things
and he's like yeah we'll probably have
to get rid of that money well so there
might be a couple ways that we can do
this if we have a decent enough I said
you know a couple cop cars I know what
it costs to rent I know what ambulances
cost to rent you know things like 350 a
day for picture vehicles some caution
tape and a few background actors walking
through making it look busy I said your
biggest issues your helicopter but we
might be able to get like a scissor lift
and you know 5k or something and do the
spotlight and then license the stock
footage shot of a 4k stock footage shot
of a police helicopter and just cut to
you know him and they're like yeah give
you I'm like because a stock footage
shot good license at 450 bucks
go on get e images and you know what we
did and we're like well look at all
these great 4k helicopter shots and you
cut that in and you can get your
helicopter I mean you can have a few cop
cars and a few ambulances and you know
whatever and it probably cost us this
much you know maybe we can do it for you
know whatever
you know have for many thousand dollars
and they were like no yeah actually so
coming up with say creative solutions
sometimes it's changes to the script or
sometimes it's like it might not be how
you're thinking but here's another way
we can do it that's an example and he
was like yeah oh this is awesome okay
great done
what would you recommend to a
screenwriter who doesn't have an agent
manager or producer to guide them so yep
I guess presuming that they're sort of
up and coming you know I think getting
an agent or a manager not both when
you're starting off is a good Avenue
because you really need an advocate I
mean a lot of writers are not
necessarily good at pitching themselves
and and even if you are there's
something that just comes off
pretentious and arrogant about talking
about how great your own work is I mean
that's good you do the writing let them
do the talking you know and so I do
think a good agent or manager I just
don't think your career is big enough
even big writers don't often need both
but just an advocate to go out and push
for you is is I think is is always
worthwhile so assume you don't know
anybody I think a good way to try to get
to an agent at manage there's a few few
good ways number one is you know
networking obviously but not necessarily
directly with agents and managers a lot
of times you can as you get to know more
people in this industry whether it's
producers DPS actors whoever you start
meeting other people who were
represented and a good way to get in
with agents and managers even better
than just meeting them at the party and
saying hey look I'm a writer you know
take an you take a look at my stuff is
knowing someone who already knows them
is oftentimes a better way to do it so
it's what's going on trying to be an
agent or major look at your own resource
base and other people you know and it's
like my friends repped by innovative
artists maybe you know hey I'll take you
out to dinner for you just yet can you
get me you know get my script over there
and get somebody to look at it or get me
a meeting I'll take you out for a nice
dinner or whatever but leverage your own
contacts because this is a relationship
business so even more than being able to
just go up to an agent and say I know
you don't know me but I'd really like to
take a look at my stuff they usually
don't but if it comes from someone they
already know and trust that's a good way
to get so look at like who you and that
that's what I've advised I have a friend
mine director who he's he's a visual
effects guy his name's Lloyd Barnett
he's an amazing visual effects guy he
was a lead compositor on Avatar and he
directed a movie I produced called ninja
apocalypse he also do a lot of visual
effects in that movie and he wants a
direct he wants do more directing so I
helped him put together the director
reel he was asking God you know how do I
get to these agents I'm like its
business a long time you have to know
people that have agents yeah I'm like
think about you know other POV effects
artists you've worked with think about
you know other you know below the line
that you've worked with composers you
have a friend he does music he might be
repped by this age you know he's ripped
by Gersh you know talk to him great see
if he can get you get your you know your
real looked at so that's one way I think
I think another way too is you know
talent rises to the top I do believe
that I do believe that talent will
eventually be rewarded real talent
unfortunately I think a lot of people
have an over overestimate their own
abilities a lot so you I think you know
you being being recognized as as
talented it's gonna be someone else
other than yourself just saying it other
other people need to recognize the
talent that that's what sort of hmm I
think that's what makes that's what I
would say actually elevates you to the
point of when when you have other people
in the industry who have some amount of
modicum of success I I think this guy's
talented I think that's that's when it's
legitimate it's great that you believe
in yourself having confidence is
fantastic I think the whole self-esteem
movement has done more to harm young
kids than help them
self-esteem is something where you know
you believe that you are owed something
that you should feel good just because
you're unique and you're this and you're
that as opposed to you know having
accomplished something and I feel like
as opposed to confidence is a different
thing believing you can go out and get
it as opposed to self-esteem believing
that you're great and you're owed
something just cuz you're unique I don't
buy that but I believe that you should
be confident you know in your in your
abilities to you know to a degree not
overconfident but be confident in
yourself that either that you have some
automatic um of talent or that
could develop the town you have into a
skill and I so I think that some people
that are good to judge to judge that is
some of the screenplay competitions some
of the better ones like and I had
written a whole article on this at funds
for writers comm I wrote a whole article
on the pros and cons of screenplay
competitions but some of the top ones
like the Sundance screenwriters lab like
the Nicholls Austin Blue cats tracking
the final drafts big break there's a few
that and I think they've elevated
themselves because they've been around
for a long time and they use a lot of
industry working industry professionals
to read the scripts and grade them so
you have people that are in the industry
that are in the know they're not just
hiring interns or kids that Kate Reed
doesn't do coverage on it but it's they
have experienced readers and when you
have enough of those competitions saying
you know I think this this guy has got
something or you know this script is
really is something else it's a fresh
voice what have you you know I think
there then there's some legitimacy to
okay this person really does have some
talent because you have some experience
third parties who have an eye for talent
this is what we do as producers as
directors right we like we identify
talent you know and I think if you can
excel in some of those competitions
you're gonna get you know hot the
opportunities to interface with agents
and managers if you get at least hit in
a big competition competition the
quarter-final level you can you can get
I think you can get agents and managers
to read your script if you can get to
the semi-final they'll probably be
calling you and if you get the finals
level you're gonna get meetings you know
if you're a finalist in Nichols you're
gonna have you're gonna you will be able
to get meetings with William Morris and
CIA because that's such a limited pool
of people compared to the number that
apply I mean literally thousands and
thousands of people apply and it gets
down to a literally a small handful of
people so I think that's another way to
get to you know to get to agents
managers so play out you're your own
resource base and see who you know
that's that's already rep and see if you
can get in that way and also
competitions I think that's too
to get to to get access to agents and
managers I understand you mentor people
up-and-coming producers young people in
the film industry
what do you see some of them struggling
with and then some of them dealing with
that they that you see as maybe a
hindrance but they don't realize it well
so let me let me just start with this uh
I you know I didn't have great mentor
experiences being a mentee when I was at
UCLA I had a mentor who was I mean I had
picked he ran a studio I thought he'd be
a great mentor Oh supposed to get three
meetings with the guy for an hour the
first meeting I said around in his
waiting room for half an hour before he
even was like oh okay yeah come in and I
might may have gotten a half hour face
time with him he told me how great oh
yeah you're doing everything right the
second meeting he pawned me off to his
creative exec I never even got to meet
with him again and then the third
meeting never even happened and I was
just really disappointed in the
experience and I said you know God you
know I would love to if I have a chance
to impart any kind of knowledge if I
ever can accrue just some piece of you
know knowledge that I feel I feel at the
point this point I can impart on on
someone else and so on a younger person
or somebody's up-and-coming and help
benefit them I really want to make sure
that I that I do it right that I put in
the time and you know really listen and
do everything that I thought I promised
I was gonna do if I said I'm gonna give
them three meetings you know I'll give
them five and really take me I really
want to make sure that if I mentored
someone that they felt like they got the
value out of it and didn't have the same
sort of letdown of an experience that I
had and I had a couple experiences like
that the UCLA one was one I had another
one as well through the producers guild
where I decided to just be a mentee and
you know be mentored by a bigger studio
producer that had doing it you know much
bigger pictures than I had been doing
because you always like I mean you're
always learning and the day you stopped
learning go home to something else why
are you doing this you know so I'm
always learning I'll be learning till
the day I die that's one of the things I
love about this but I want to make sure
that the mentors the men the mentees
that I was mentoring we're not having
that sort of negative experience and
they were really getting something out
of it
and so so I've mentored a few people
through the producers guild mentorship
program I really do like it I think it's
a great program so like let's say you
know some 20-something cat who's been
doing reality TV he did a segment
producer he's been a field producer but
he wants to do movies what you know I
want to be an indie producer and that's
where so many of them want to go even
with the whole new media thing
traditional feature films a lot of
younger producers still want to do
feature films so they might be
experienced producers in their own right
but in the whole different video games
or news or reality TV or something they
want to do features and I'll walk them
you know through the problem meet with
them I might let them shadow me one of
them I let him come to a sound mix soon
yeah and it was it was funny because
reality TV is totally different so we're
sitting in the sound mix and I said to
him you know come stay as long as you
want and if you want to chime in with an
idea please go ahead tell us and we're
sitting there we're doing a scene he
kind of jumps he goes hey here's an idea
we guys think if you just like got rid
of that whole part of the end of scene
just ended it right there and I'm like
I'm like what do you mean he's like so
if see where this okay right here where
the scene ends just like cut out that
whole part and just cut right to the
scene I go you talk about editing he's
like yeah my going ahead
I said where the sound makes the picture
has been locked for months I said oh
he's like oh I'm like once you're in
audio on a feature film and you're
especially the sound mix this picture
has been law not one frame of the
picture is changing at this point he's
like oh in reality it's totally there I
didn't know in reality while they're
doing sound they're also cutting let's
just lose that okay bump that sound up
it's a whole different workflow of a
different post workflow it's much you
know kind of more nimble and while
features like you lock picture and now
you start not sound and visual effects
and music but you got to lock the
picture first and not one frame of that
picture is changing and he didn't
realize that so he learned so okay and I
feel like you know just seeing I don't
even know if I'm answering your question
yeah but seeing that these calm kids
because they're younger than me but
these these these people these younger
producers are
really getting something out of the
process and learning something that they
taking art skills they already have and
expanding them like the are you have
some understanding about post workflow
as an example what they don't know how
it translates into other areas of
entertainment or other media and/or some
of the things we've talked about on
script development you know like okay
they have some understanding of story so
I you know some of these people that
already have an interest in some
experience but I can take it to maybe a
different level or in an area where I
have more experience than them I really
enjoy that and I feel like I get
something back as well because I often
learn from them because they bring some
sort of knowledge that I didn't know
about from their areas and a lot of
times it can translate into slide sort
of mutually beneficial working
relationships in the future and I even
tried to do mentor even if it's not a
formal mentor program sometimes I've
done interviews with these younger cats
that got podcasts and what-have-you and
they it was great talk and you if I have
questions about if I'm working on a
script could I call you or email you I
guess sure please I'm very open and very
willing to to do that I don't think I
think people that try to you know Ike
hold on to knowledge and and and you
know keep it keep it for themselves I
think wind up doing themselves a
disservice because I think sharing
knowledge and having dialog with with
other people with people that have
different views and different ideas and
different knowledge about different
areas I think that helps you grow as a
producer as well that dialogue and the
information you know that you get and
also it helps you I think a lot of times
formulate your own thoughts and your own
ideas when you're faced with now having
to tutor somebody now you really have to
like you think about what you're what
you're gonna say and what you're gonna
impart and how that functions in the
real world it's not just philosophy it's
it's got to be put to some sort of
practical application you know and I
think that's um that's one of the things
I enjoy I enjoy that dialogue well you
know you always hear that well back in
my day we had it so much harder and I
try to think about if I were a
millennial today it'd actually be
probably more difficult than when I was
looking for a job when I was younger in
the 90s when you him
was coming up and what is this you know
the tech bubble and all that but yeah
there's social media which is great but
then there's also the dark side which is
everyone's comparing their life online
so there's this inherent like
inferiority that everyone thinks
everybody else is doing better than they
are and then there's also whether they
were affected by the recession their
parents probably were so I started to
think you know what actually Millennials
may have it tougher I know right now
there's this huge debate about old
Millennials and this and that and some
of the stereotypes may be true I won't
you know say that that's not true but I
think that it would be in some sense
more difficult today but maybe I'm wrong
do you think that they have it tougher
or or it's just a different set of
challenges
I you know my whole view on life is
trade-offs trade-offs trade-offs
trade-offs that's what life is all about
there's an end with with Millennials and
the newer generation it's the same but
there's always pros and cons so like for
example what you were talking about I
think the new media in terms of
Technology in terms of access to being
able to create entertainment oh yeah I
mean clearly Millennials have it better
in terms of access to prosumer
technology and they can get their hands
on red cameras an area Lexus and the
same stuff big TV shoot on and they can
cut on Final Cut and you know Adobe
Premiere same stuff that bigger shows
cut Ivy had access to things wall 30
years ago I mean you're not gonna get a
pay a quarter million dollar Panavision
camera and you're not gonna be able to
edit that yeah when I was a kid we were
editing our little videos with two VCRs
play record and pause you know I mean it
was that's how you were having to cut
your videos these you know the younger
generation is access and also access to
new distribution platforms ways to get
their stuff seeing that 30 years ago was
unheard of a like television and movie
theaters you know and you know to some
degree home video but it was you know
was it was different now they have
through through streaming and and you
know online if so many other ways to get
their content seen but then with that
comes negatives I mean so there's a lot
because new what more access means more
competition and there's you know so the
content media space is so fractured and
there's so many different
competing for eyeballs and so many
people now creating YouTube videos and
creating content and what-have-you that
that space is becoming really crowded as
opposed to like we were talking about
earlier with blood simple or Sex Lies
and videotape there wasn't really indie
filmmakers out there doing so it's like
wow this is you know they were but it
was much harder for them to get access I
mean buying film and that kind of
equipment and you know it was much more
expensive and so again there's
trade-offs there's pros and cons to
everything I think so in some ways they
have it better in some ways I think they
have it they have a tougher red flags of
a distribution deal red flags of a
distribution deal safe one of the
toughest for last sorry actually you
know actually maybe not because when I'm
so a lot of the pictures I do are home
entertainment titles nothing to say
pictures that'll go too
theatrical if they do they'll go limited
theatrical and I think a lot of times
when I look at a contract yeah I'm
looking at the marketing and how much
they're saying the marketing is gonna
cost a lot of the distributors that I
try to avoid are these are these guys
that putting their contracts that well
they're gonna spend fifty or
seventy-five thousand dollars or a
hundred thousand dollars on PA and
marketing and I'm like well what exactly
are you gonna spend that money on
because to get the guy the average guy
just walking down the street to see your
movie like you need five million dollars
minimum I mean you need huge amounts of
PA just to get that random guy walking
down the street to even know what your
movie is I mean the amount of money it
takes to market billboards and bus
shelters and both sides and TV spots and
online and getting that banner on IMDB
on the front it cost millions millions
of dollars to do a campaign wide enough
to really draw those kind of eyeballs
Home Entertainment is such a different
beast it's a lot of it's done through
now social media through free publicity
getting interviews and junkets with your
actors or getting reviews written up and
that sort of thing or you know throw
their creative non expensive forms of
marketing like for example you know when
you go into Xbox or Netflix and it says
you might also like and list getting
high up on that algorithm where your
film is listed with some big film you
might also like this little film that
means so much more to a
smaller to a smaller film or just
getting you know an end cap in Walmart
is a huge that may not cost you a lot do
that but if you have a distributor that
has a relationship that can do that
that's what happened with ninja
apocalypse we got an end cap in Walmart
and in Best Buy
and that didn't cost anything extra that
with but that was sort of smart and you
know a distributor using relationships
something that's how you have to get
your film them premiering at a really
festival it's got you know really good
promotional sponsorship and and press
behind it we premiered ninja pocalypse
at comic-con in San Diego perfect right
and so instead of spending millions and
millions of hours you have it's more
things like that that I look for so when
I see a distribution contract that says
oh we're gonna spend $75,000 in
marketing like on what what are you
spending that on well we gotta cut
trailers like I can cut a trailer I can
get cut tailor cut 4 grand what else
well you know got to do posters I'm like
same thing I mean I have designers it
can be posed I would rather do those
things and instead of having the
distributor bill some enormous markup
and a lot of times if they have $75,000
marketing expense built in you're not
gonna see any money until that seventy
five thousand is recouped it's not like
they're gonna say well we've only spent
10 of it so okay we'll start cutting you
checks now no they're gonna keep saying
oh well you know we haven't hit that
seventy five thousand dollar marketing
cap so I really look at you know that
number how much they're spending and it
should be a smaller number and I want to
know honestly what it is I want it to be
something we actually a chance at making
some getting a recoupment here and not
you have to you know you have to make
seventy five or a hundred grand before
we even see the first dollar because on
a million dollar picture I mean it's not
you're not going to be out there in
theaters you know making thirty million
dollars so the economics are different
and how that money has been spent is
different so things like going to film
markets that's a reasonable justifiable
distribution expense and then marketing
expenses you know you know there's
there's certain you know cut cutting
trailers can be reasonable as long as I
know you know okay what they're spending
I like to use
have the ability to approve any expense
over a certain amount so I know that
they're not being unreasonable you know
and then there could be you know working
meals lunches with buyers things like
that are reasonable but up to a certain
amount so so I'm usually looking for
that number to be you know curtailed
somewhat and then in terms of the term
of the distribution contract a lot of
times you know seven years this is
pretty standard but they're you know
very you know I would almost never do
anything in perpetuity you know and then
sometimes you see contracts over ten
years or 12 years that might be that
seemed a little excessive in terms of
fees you know but for me I'm kind of
looking around the twenty percent range
in terms of what I'm willing to pay a
distributor some charge as much as 30
percent or more so you know you know red
flags to me are typically you know term
fees marketing expenses are the first
and then you know other than that you're
just looking at is sort of any onerous
language that ties you to something you
don't want to be tied to like oh we want
rights to a few to all the future
sequels or something and you know look
unless you're willing to invest money in
those future sequels I mean we're only
talking about this picture you know
right here so so yeah and then you know
I think you can tell reputable
distributors to just by the language of
their contracts a lot of times to a few
little things like if you start to see a
lot of like typos and spelling mistakes
and grammar mistakes and this is a
distributor not familiar with to me
that's a red flag because any legitimate
distributor is gonna have a legitimate
attorney drafting those contracts I
don't want us see them riddled with
mistakes I typically don't deal with
distributors that I've never heard of
usually they come to me by way of
someone who I know who's worked with
them or I you know they've been around
for a while I know their work and I try
so I try to stick with with distributors
that I already know have a good
reputation I already know people have
worked with them I've said good things
about them so I don't have to worry
about a lot of those a lot of those
issues